it is the most competitive of the three
of you one of us we're all kind of
competitive you know you can't get too
far in our business without having a
little bit of competition to you but
I'll probably probably rent her I think
he's the one that's feeling it the most
but you know we always had to remind him
you know it's written that you always
succeed in this I wanted to I could put
my hand on here but we had a blast
making the film and it's uh I think it I
think it shows itself when you see it
the chemistry between us is really is
really real and it's really fun and it's
like a bunch of idiots being idiotic and
that's a that's a good thing to not lose
and whose idea was it to crash that
wedding that was amazing you know we
were who saw it happening we're like oh
my gosh that's kind of there like we
should just go say hi and we sent
rendering first we were like no you know
somebody's like oh my god that's hot guy
we're like okay we're in everybody yeah
they were very very sweet
we were sweet um you know a lot of you
your ass members one movie that you
would love to join yeah you know it's
interesting I've actually joined most of
the ones that I'd like to join I mean
I've been on Black Mirror I'm on Kimmy
Schmidt the one that I'm watching now
that I think is really good is Atlanta
Donald Glover is Atlanta I think that
shows taking some real cool risks and
from both the narrative and a filmmaking
standpoint I'd like to be on that show
that'd be pretty fun
if you like laughter if you're like
friends feel like a good time go see
this movie it is really funny it's hard
funny it is rated R so I don't know what
that means up here you got to be metric
18 years old
I'm not sure but it's it's really funny
and it's got a lot of heart so
I'm really proud of it congratulations
thanks man thanks let's talk about it